ai ragazzi dai gusti pazzi come state
nel caso vi state chiedendo perché sta
indossando questo cappello per questo
motivo qua lo rimettiamo signori viene
da una vita che aspettavo questo momento
perché sono arrivato fino a questo punto
in pokémon per riuscire a registrare
questo ma lentissimo video che per
registrarci 24 ore quindi sono a scherzi
non avere uno scherzo
vabbè aperte le cagate durante le
vacanze ho giocato a poche non un sacco
ho finito il pokédex infatti non mi
ricordo come si chiama
mio padre però ho finito tutto il poker
iss come potete vedere qui a squadre mi
faccio vedere ora che bella nim azione
da youtube professionista eccolo qua
sotto c'è scritto lori biancavilla poche
651 sono bravissimo grazie tutte le
ragazze il mio numero e ve lo lascio
descrizione perché ho finito il pokédex
perché sul po che non c'è una cosa
che puoi fare che sarebbe la caccia ai
pokémon shining cosa un pò comincia in
borgo shiny è un pokémon di colore
diverso inoltre sbrilluccica un po come
edward in twilight roba lì poi forse non
lo sapete ma c'è una possibilità su 4096
che sono tante che un pokémon riesca
shiny ora chi si mette a dare la caccia
a questi pokemon shiny deve veramente
cercarli su 4096 no perché ci sono dei
modi per facilitare la cattura di questi
pokemon shiny che avere un oggetto che
si chiama shiny charm per avere questo
oggetto shiny charm cosa devi fare di
avere completato il pokédex e poi devi
andare da quelle professorone che non sa
manco se siete maschio femmina che però
in grado di darvi questo oggetto io ho
finito il pokédex stamattina e sono
pronto ad andare dal professor hoc che
mi da questo shiny charm che è l'oggetto
per trovare più facilmente lee child
let's be friends allora ho salvato
esattamente nel momento in cui il
professore misura dallo scenario quindi
perfetto non l'ho fatto per lo faccio
per voi come volete vedere my friends
questo il mio pokédex che mostra con
orgoglio alla gente o tutti ai 151 in
pokémon
sono contento di essere al mondo siamo
pronti ad andare dal professor hoc e
vedere se ci dà sto maledettissimo cia
di ciancio nessuna vita prendono quindi
da me lo grazia e gentilissimo che
piacere gli altri come va con il poker
sono finito ed eccoti il mio giudizio
per ora barabba grazie mille professore
adesso sì che tutta la fagiana per me
quasi non ci crede copiato il pokédex
non ci credo anche io e incredibile
encomiabile magnifico ma che dico
superlativo
wow grazie lori grazie ricordo grazie a
te grazie attrezzi è riuscito a ridare
mio sogno tuo sogno dove ogni oggetto
cosa me ne frega il tuo sogno
dammi l'oggetto per non è lui che velo
da lui minuti dall oggetto o che ragazzo
scoperto come si fa tra l'altro ragazzi
non guardate la mia squadra che fa un pò
schifo perché sto allenando i miei
pokémon però dragoni te posso fare
questo e non so se potete farlo voi il
che mi rende felicissimo allora ragazzi
lo shiny charm si dovrebbe trovare qua
dentro e non avevo idea pensate adesso
il professor hoc che di già non sapevo
sta cosa ottimo proprio perché non ho
aspettato di fare questo video per
prendere voce per per parlo con voi
pensate quanto sono buono
eccolo lo zio da melo veloce dicono che
melo da lui è finalmente uscita come
dalle poche l'ex bomber di natale
veramente riconoscimento ufficiale
diploma come il diploma andato il
diploma ti sembra la faccia di uno da
diploma questo però vale grazie
e per festeggiare anche primo per per te
o chrome amuleto cosa diavolo è chrome
amuleto spiegami aumentate perché non
cromatici ok ok ok ok io lo chiamo shiny
charmet perché in inglese è giusto così
quindi ragazzi finalmente la mia
probabilità di catona lisciani è scesa
da 1 su 4600 96 ad uno e 1.300 se non
sbaglio mi 300 qualcosa ovviamente non
lo troverò mai in un video a meno che
non farci una cosa i pokemon
sgocciola possibilità ancora maggiore di
trovare di shining se fai le combo cosa
sono le combo devi catturare un pokémon
tante volte di fila lo stesso tipo di
pokémon fino ad arrivare una combo di 31
sarebbe un racconto gli 31 pokémon la
pro vita che ti escano shiny è di 1 su
300 che è comunque poco ma è meglio di
uno su 4 mila non lo so se ci riesco in
sto video vediamo se riuscirò a
catturare uno charme per avere tutti e
151 i pokémon io ho dovuto catturare le
prime evoluzioni tipo bulba saur e farlo
diventare allenandolo venosa nel mentre
che stavo cercando di far evolvere tutti
i pokemon per completare il pokédex al
centocinquantesimo quindi stamattina
quando allenato l'ultimo pokémon ho
trovato uno shiny completamente a caso
non senza fare combo senza averlo shiny
charm quindi uno su 4096 l'ho trovato a
caso stamattina e si tratta di goldbet
cielo shiny l'ho trovato stamattina ve
lo giuro su dio gioca poco ma da
vent'anni lavanda o tre anni non mi è
mai capitato di trovare un osceni mai e
mi è successo quando stavo a 150 pokémon
del pokédex il ministro quando stavo per
prendere osceni charm può anche il video
di quando l'ho catturato magari ve lo
lascio in un elencato in descrizione ma
per culo culo incredibile lo sta facendo
la combo di niente cioè mi è capitato a
caso mentre le navi pokémon
direi che possiamo catturare o tentare
dica perché non non riuscirò mai però
proviamoci un gili paz shiny perché li
vedo che scorazzano belli belli qua
quindi premo gili paz shiny ragazzi devo
fare una combo di 31 catture sarà
impossibile però vabbè proviamoci
ecco se lancio così le poi le mie ultra
vol iniziamo malissimo però va beh
il primo è andato da farne 31 ragazzi
quindi velocità maggiore in editing
signori siamo giunti all'ultimo gili paz
della giornata cioè spero il penultimo e
l'ultimo ad essere uno shiny queste
31esimo poi dovremmo aver finito la
combo nel senso che dopo il 31 non si
può più andare avanti
adesso le probabilità che esca un gb
shiny sono una su 273 se non sbaglio
sono simpatici da vedere mentre
camminano perché sono teneri non lo so
si passano attraverso sono troppo teneri
ho scelto il pokémon giusto per
cominciare la caccia di shining ho letto
ragazzi in giro nel mentre che sto
aspettando
i cicli basket paulinho che se tu
volando certo torni indietro tipo
aspetti qualche secondo poi ritorni
avanti
tranne store attuata maledetto tutti gli
altri pokémon rispondono quindi c'è
ancora sta cioè il modo migliore per
cercare di far sparare 1 shine ho letto
anche questo al bari non la sapevo
quindi ancora più figo che la combo non
non è per forza dei gg.ii pace nel senso
io ho fatto una combo di scicli parti 31
e c'è la stessa probabilità che miss
pavani anche un char izzard shiny quindi
vi conviene se volete fare sta roba
catture tipo 30 magica accusandole
pokémon gesù buon dio si zitti zitti
tutti zitti
cos'è qua prendilo subito poi ha subito
usa la madonna prendi quello che vuoi ti
prego
andiamo a berlino col ciari sardinero
che figo
mentre stavo spiegando la faccenda
proprio incredibile
sto male sto male anche perché non me lo
sarei mai aspettato me n'ero ce l'ho ce
l'ho l'ho presa e l'orto male sto male
bene la patata a me stavo esattamente
spiegando questo nel senso che catturi
31 che non ne fai la combo e poi non è
quel pokemon che ti esce shiny poi
usciti qualsiasi pokémon shining e
mentre lo spiegavo mi è uscito charles
shar is hard and shiney ok venne molto
contento di prima fantastico ripetendo
il discorso vi conviene catone tipo 30
magica alto che siano sprecate neanche
le ultra voi come ho fatto io che non
sapevo e vi beccate direttamente la
combo quei magica che tanto fanno schifo
se invece come mai catturati appunto un
altro pokémon adesso la combo mi si è
spezzata perché ho catturato un charles
hall che proverà in e quindi fighissimo
era più probabile che mi uscisse un gb
of china che quando catturi tipo tanti
cicli paffet ti escono molti pg biba
quindi è più probabile perché te ne
escono tanti ma la probabilità è sempre
una su 273 tra tutti i pokémon che ci
sono e mentre lo spiegavo uscito
già richard che fa un po schifo di
statistiche ma chi se ne frega perché
adesso io volo su c'è richard nero
fatemi vedere come la questo gioco è la
vita e la vita ci ho messo in totale
allora circa 45 minuti poco meno di
un'ora in realtà quindi catturate
pokémon che fanno schifo usate 30
pokémon 31 pokémon non le ultra
incredibile incredibile babich arisa di
più raro tra tutti basta sono con tetto
questo rinchiudere chiave benissimo qui
i ragazzi questo è più o meno come
cattura uno shiny neanche io sapevo bene
come fare l'ho scoperto meglio qua vi
consiglio appunto di fare come sto
facendo io c'è uscite dopo che avete
catturato la combo ri 30 dopo che avete
lo charme dopo che usate il profumo come
sta votando io se siete tipo all'aperto
uscite dalla zona di spam e rientrate in
modo che paolino spalmi un po di gente
va bene ragazzuoli sono sono felicissimo
non so come ho fatto giuro per
festeggiare chiudo il video che i miei
capelli normali bene questi sono shiny
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come un servizio video religioso cenno
al momento mi piace molto meglio di
quanto pensassi dato vita anche per i
soci non descrizione fatemi sapere se i
video così vi piacciono magari che li
porto anche in live lo shiny hunting ad
un prossimo shining si spera sono troppo
le urgenze ragazzi
[Musica]